brian loftis and i'm denise valdez a
thai restaurant in centennial hills
officially reopening today this after it
was closed for weeks for an
investigation into how dozens of
customers got sick after eating there
now we do have team coverage on this
first we're going to get to victoria
saha who spoke with the new supervising
employee about the accusations
it's been a long road to get to this
open sign for secret of siam they
welcomed customers back in today after
an investigation took place to see what
made almost 30 customers sick
secret of siam is waiting for seats to
be filled again after the health
district ordered it to close in february
the one thing that i would like to say
is a welcome to our restaurant we will
do our best for our customers a new
supervisor for the restaurant
wearabuanano only wanted us to record
her voice she is hoping to gain the
community's trust back for the
restaurant we are very sure that we will
serve the safe food back in february a
police investigation followed the
strange illnesses involving dozens of
customers who tested positive for thc
and cannabinoids which is an ingredient
found in marijuana documents show a
container of curry powder was found that
tested positive for thc but how it got
there still remains a mystery we try so
hard to find out as well
and just
now from here
we just want to do our best
more carefully their first day back in
business welcomed customers like evelyn
gallardo who was waiting to try the thai
restaurant for a while i recommend it to
my friends if we could all meet up over
here because i know for sure they're
going to be more strict with their food
regulations they'll be following the
health guidelines things like that so i
know it's going to be safer bouinano
says she has talked to every staff
member and will keep an extra eye out
for the new workers to ensure this
incident doesn't happen again metro
police had closed their investigation
earlier this month after they say that
there was no criminal intent behind this
the southern nevada health district is
still investigating but they gave the
restaurant the green light to reopen but
they must follow specific protocols
reporting from secret of siam victoria
saha live local now